a
l'espoir de traitements
prometteurs contre la maladie.
L'OMS a d'ailleurs recommandé
deux nouveaux traitements
vendredi. Commençons avec
les trairps monoclonaux.
- Le médicament dont on parle...
difficiles à prononcer. Ce sont
des anticorps qui ont été créés
artificiellement et qui cible
directement les parties du virus
virus ne puisse pas s'attaquer,
s'attacher à la cellule. On se
patients à recevoir un ant
monoclonal. C'était en 2020.
On a vu qu'en 48 heures, il
s'est remis. Ces anticorps
Canada et au Québec et continu à
la mettre. Malheureusement,
ils ne sont plus efficaces
contre le micro parce qu'il aaaa
muté. Mais ce médi
très efficace. Il
auprès des patients à haut
risque d'avoir des
complica
personnes âgées, de personnes
qui ont
e. Ces patients peuvent
être traités par ce médicament.
Mais il faut que ce soit
jours. Il faut qu'on puisserecet
rapidement. C'est une infusion
par intraveineuse. Ça se fait
prometteur, mais il y a une
certaine lourdeur dans la façon
de l'appliquer. Les médecins
les hôpitaux le veulent, mais on
attend plus de doses. On n'en a
n'en veut beaucoup plus. Et le
fabricant va essayer de le faire
le plus rapidement possible.
- Et avec Pfizer m
- Avec Pule.
C'est un médicament qui
s'appelle Paxlovid. Il est
efficaceintéressant.
ant ces exant ces exant ces exaa
collègue qui va nous montrer
comment le Paxlovid fonctionne.
- Le virus du SARS-CoV-2
a besoin de nous p
reproduire. Quand il entre
dans nos cellules, son matériel
génétiquine.
D'abord sous forme d'une lonêtre
découpée en plusieurs morceaux.,
une protéase.
Pour stopper le virus dans
sa progression, la molécule
l'action de cette protéase.êcheu
virus de se former correctement
et donc de servir à fabriqu
comprend aussi une deuxième
molécule antiviral
habituellement utilisée contre
le VIH, qui ralentit
pour prolonger son action.
L'essai clinique de Pfizer a étt
pas vaccinés.
Près de 1000 adul présentai prét
au moins un facteur de risquedea
COVID-19 ont reçu le médicament
après avoir déve
maladie et
près de 1000 autres ont reçu
un placebo.
66 personnes qui ont reçu le
placebo ont dû être hospitalisée
décédées, alors que 8 personnes
aitement
ont dû être soignées à
l'hôpital. Ça correspond à une